[Musik]
im ukraine krieg hoffen zurzeit alle auf
einen sieg der diplomatie
meingast heute sagt das sind nicht die
zeiten der diplomatie sondern die der
waffen
professor sogar das ein furchtbares
fazit ja es ist ein furchtbares fazit
aber ich fürchte dass zu diesem
zeitpunkt jetzt putin entschlossen ist
diesen krieg militärisch zu entscheiden
dass er nicht bereit ist kompromisse
einzugehen und es ist glaube ich leider
so das ist nicht die stunde der
diplomatie ist sondern dass putin
versuchen wird die sind konflikt
militärisch zu entscheiden sie sind
militärhistoriker wenn wir den anfang
dieses krieges uns anschauen vor 14
tagen dann hatte man den eindruck
russland schätzt die situation so ein
mann geht in die ukraine rein besiegt
den feind kopiert das land und das ist
nach ein paar tagen oder zumindest noch
ein paar wochen geschehen jetzt haben
wir den eindruck die ukraine ist viel
stärker und putin ist schwächer ja das
würde ich genauso unterschreiben und ich
glaube dass diese analyse auch die
meisten westlichen analysten haben ich
glaube nicht dass es das ist sehr viele
geheimdienstberichte gab wenn wir das
als ist rücker mal in 30 jahren
erforschen die sagen putin wird in einen
wochenlangen abnutzungskrieg gezogen was
wir jetzt sehen also die wahrnehmung war
die russland hat sehr viel in seinen
militär investiert das hat das
modernisiert sie haben im kampf
erfahrungen gesammelt wir haben in
syrien hat die luftwaffe gezeigt was sie
kann um das jetzt mal vom handwerk zu
sehen da waren die westlichen analysten
eher überrascht was die russen dort
alles machen natürlich fürchterlich also
bombardierungen aber sie waren uns auch
vom militärischen handwerk ziemlich
präzise und jeder hat eigentlich die
russen als auch die luftlande kräfte als
ziemlich professionell wahrgenommen und
putin hat sich völlig verkalkuliert aber
ich glaube auch der westen weil das hat
der ukrainische botschafter ja deutlich
gemacht als er romy vom ersten zweiten
tag um hilfe gebeten hat es ist ja
offenbar so gewesen dass er als antwort
bekam er also die ukraine fällt doch
sowieso bald wir müssen euch gar nicht
mehr helfen also haben wir haben sich
alle glaube ich war kalkuliert aber
jetzt fragt man sich natürlich wenn ihr
einen solchen angriffskrieg inszenieren
dann habe ich eine gewisse strategie und
das kennen sie ja nun aus der geschichte
exzellent das was wir erfahren haben ist
aber eine gewisse taktik war putin wie
kann er sich so vor schätzen ich habe
also ich glaube alle westlichen aber
viele westliche analysten haben immer
argumentiert er wird diesen krieg nicht
führen weil er die ukraine nicht
beherrschen können er kann sie
vielleicht besetzten militärisch
taktisch aber er wird diesen krieg
politisch wirtschaftlich verlieren und
das ist ja genau der grund gewesen warum
mal gesagt hat er macht es nicht weil
man putin er
vorsichtiger gewaltbereite siehe
georgien siehe tschetschenien aber doch
er hat eben 2014 nicht das baltikum an
begriffen was seine militärische machen
können sondern nur in anführungsstrichen
die krim so und was jetzt sein kalkül
ist
da rätseln ja aber jetzt rum es ist
rätsel ja alle rum und wir sehen dass
wir das aus einem einem einer westlichen
logik sehen sagen wie viel er denn eine
eine pro russische regierung in kiew
installieren wo jetzt wirklich fast alle
ukraine
putin und die russen lassen nach diesem
krieg wie wie soll das gehen also das
ist ein großes fragezeichen wie das
gehen soll aber offensichtlich hat putin
eine ganz andere logik und denkt in
längeren in längeren linien und wir alle
glauben dass er sich dass er das nicht
erwartet hat nur er kann dazu entsteht
mit dem rücken an der wand er kann ja
nicht sagen sorry hab mich geirrt war
nicht so gemeint sondern er muss jetzt
diesen krieg durch flächen wenn wir die
beiden
sehen nämlich putin und der ukrainischen
präsidenten satinsky der eine enorme
ausstrahlungskraft gewonnen hat auch
durch die medien durch seine exzellente
kommunikation fährt frage ich mich
natürlich das ist eine spezialität nicht
nur der russen immer gewesen diese
kommunikation sondern auch von putin
selber der geheimdienstler war warum
diese fehleinschätzung weil es hätte
alles funktionieren glaube ich oder
besser funktioniert wenn der kuh in den
ersten 48 stunden geklappt hätte denn
wenn die russischen streitkräfte nach
kiew marschiert werden luft gelandet die
ukrainische mir auseinander gefallen
dann hätte man von spezialoperationen
das haben die amerikaner auch gemacht
und so und dann an fair company und dann
freundlich gegen den westen diese ganze
strategie ist jetzt natürlich zerfallen
weil was soll das argument sein also
offensichtlich kommen die russen nicht
als befreier das kann man beim besten
willen nicht behaupten wie
offensichtlich haben die russen hohe
verluste für die ukrainische verluste
kann man vielleicht gleich nach drüber
reden und es ist offensichtlich den
russischen hacker nicht gelungen die
kommunikation von präsidenten zu stören
oder auch die ganze kommunikation namen
zulegen jetzt wissen wir warum wir zu
wissen dass diese kommunikation über
diese lynskey spricht mit uns allen wenn
amerikaner geliefert wurde also er kann
verschlüsselt kommunizieren und das ist
natürlich für die hosen ein super-gau
dass dieser präsident zu einer ikone
wird und als anfang an hält sich sagen
inszeniert und danke hat putin nichts
dagegenzusetzen er bräuchte erfolge er
bräuchte militärische erfolg er bräuchte
ukrainische gefangene die sagen wir sind
für russland aber die hat ja es ist
kommunikativ eine katastrophe gehabt wir
haben ja eher das gegenteil
vom eindruck her ist es ja so dass die
russische armee ein bisschen so dasteht
wie so ein bisschen trottelig in einen
krieg gezogen von dem sie nicht wussten
was ist denn da eigentlich los viele
sollen angeblich gehört haben bei ihrem
einsatzbefehl es geht in eine übung und
finden sich in einem land wieder was ja
auch noch immer wieder als bruder laden
bezeichnet worden ist da muss ich
trotzdem noch mal die frage stellen was
kann denn der grund gewesen sein dass
putin an krieg beginnt
mit sehr wenig informationen es gibt ein
sehr interessante studie der der
universität st gallen die zeigt über die
letzten zehn jahre dass die orientierung
in der ukraine sehr eindeutig den westen
geht dass man gar nicht sehr russen
freundlich ist und wenn man diese studie
sieht dann muss das doch auch der
geheimdienst in moskau gehabt haben da
muss es doch putin gewusst habe die
frage ist nur ob dieser geheimdienst
darüber berichten konnte die frage ist
nur ob auch die generäle ehrlich
berichten konnten über den zustand ihrer
truppen und wir haben in geheimdienst-
forschung ja etwas phänomen der
politischen anpassung von finck in
kann es zum beispiel ist 2003 der irak
massenvernichtungswaffen
sowohl die briten wie die amerikaner die
geheimdienste die ganz unterschiedlich
strukturiert sind beide hunters gemeldet
warum weil die politiker es hören wollen
und weil nachrichtendienste in diesem
fall ist nicht sich durchsetzen konnten
mit informationen die man nicht hören
wollte und die frage ist ja immer wie
funktioniert wissensproduktion in einem
staat wie wird aus information wissen
wird es verteilt und wir wissen das ja
aus der geschichte hitlers darlehen aber
eben auch 2003 bush und blair dass sie
die wahrheit hören wollten und dass sie
letztlich vorgegeben haben was die
nachrichtendienste zu berichten haben
und das ist möglicherweise auch das
problem bei putin wie offen kann ich als
nachrichtendienst chef eigentlich
berichten wenn wir an diese
befehlsausgabe da denken wir den chef
des auslandsgeheimdiensts um inne
gemacht hat macht auf mich nicht den
eindruck als ob es da eine band of
brothers ist die jetzt ganz offen auch
kritisch berichten können
wir müssen ein bisschen darüber sprechen
was wir eigentlich gar nicht gerne hören
wollen nämlich über die waffen
die russische armee in den letzten
jahren mit hochtechnologie versorgt
worden das sind enorme summen
reingegangen man muss jetzt leider auch
unterstellen das war schon absicht für
das was jetzt passiert ist warum werden
die nicht in dem maße eingesetzt wer die
große frage ist wie viel ich sage mal
smart backens haben die russen überhaupt
also zb leser gipsfuß muss also in der
ersten woche sind glaube ich etwa 180
cruise missiles abgeschlossen worden ist
noch relativ überschaubar
wir wissen dass russland das hat wir
wissen dass sie sagen auch
hochtechnologie haben aber diese dinge
sind sehr sehr teuer und wir sehen das
in libyen das mit den franzosen auch
sehr schnell die bomben die die dann die
intelligenten bomben ausgegangen und
dann müssen wir auch immer bedenken
putin muss ja kalkulieren dass im
schlimmsten fall ist zu einem konflikt
mit der nato kommt das vielleicht doch
aufgrund irgendeines szenarios die nato
mit ihrer läufer verein greift und für
diesen fall
braucht er ja auch seine seine smart
weapons und seiner hochtechnologie also
ich glaube schon dass ich glaube ich die
russischen waffenarsenale mit
hochtechnologie nicht so voll sind wie
wir dachten und zweiter punkt dass putin
gerade seine seine seine high tech
waffen ob das die panzer sind ob das zum
teil die flugzeuge sind zurückhält für
den fall dass ist wirklich zu einem
krieg mit der natur damit muss er nicht
bei sat 1 hat es könnte aber doch auch
sagen dass man die verhandlungsposition
noch mal verbessert will wenn ich einer
zweiten phase die sich ja jetzt andeutet
also eine phase wo man merkt so geht's
nicht vorwärts
zumindest aus sicht moskaus
vielleicht dann doch hochtechnologie
einsetzt um bestimmte ziele zu erreichen
greift zum beispiel einer zunehmen etc
wäre die verhandlungsposition ja für ihn
besser ich glaube das hätte er längst
machen müssen ich glaube der
ursprüngliche plan war innerhalb von 48
stunden die ukraine ich sage mal in
anführungsstrichen zu enthaupten das ist
nicht passiert
und eigentlich hätte ich erwartet dass
putin danach
viel stärker auf auf waffentechnik setzt
sich bislang nicht eingesetzt hat und
wir sind jetzt nun in der zweiten woche
also jeder tag den dieser krieg dauert
ist es ein stück weit
verliert putin einstecken ist das hätte
das nach wer nach den ersten drei tagen
ist das der grund warum wir schon nach
ein paar tagen gehört haben wir können
uns auch vorstellen atomwaffen
einzusetzen ist das eine drohung gewesen
die diesen druck erzeugen sorgen also es
war die der die horrorvorstellung für
putin ist ja dass sich die nato
einmischt denn eins ist auch klar wenn
es eine konventionelle
auseinandersetzung etwa im luftkrieg
gibt da hat muss dann glaube ich relativ
schlechte karten und er muss das um mit
allen mitteln verhindern er muss ja auch
verhindern eigentlich dass
waffenlieferungen an die ukraine gibt
und er kann das ja nur mit der drohung
eines atomkrieges jetzt ist auch diese
drohung zwar ausgesprochen er hat sagen
die zweite von vier stufen der
alarmierung gemacht aber er hat eben
auch nicht die vierte stufe genommen
also auch da ist noch sagen potenzial
und er versucht die nato rauszuhalten
aber seine möglichkeiten sind natürlich
auch prominenz da müssen wir aber
vielleicht auch ein bisschen
unterscheiden in der öffentlichen
wahrnehmung sieht man ja strategische
atomwaffen im einsatz das muss ja gar
nicht sein das können ja auch taktische
sein das sind waffen die auf relativ
kurze distanz in anführungsstrichen
eingesetzt werden aber eine verheerende
wirkung habe war dass die drohung damit
ja also die große frage ist ja unter
welchen bedingungen wer putin bereit
atomwaffen einzusetzen nicht und es gibt
experten die sagen er könnte vielleicht
eine atomwaffe über der ostsee zünden
über dem schwarzen meer einfach als
warnung an die nato und das ist nicht
also der grund warum jetzt die mig 29
nicht geliefert worden sind ist glaube
ich auch bei den amerikaner wenn wir das
zu offensichtlich machen zu demonstrativ
da eingreifen dann könnte putin die
nächste eskalationsstufe geben das
wollen wir nicht
aus meiner sicht so weit ich die nato
kollegen kenne sind die nicht der
meinung dass putin jetzt ein fluglehrer
walking die nato beginnt aber kam es
nach dem 24 februar noch irgendeine
gewissheit gebe also sicherlich gut auf
sich zurückzuhalten und putin wird alles
versuchen die nato abzuschrecken und
unsere angst zu spielen damit wir der
ukraine nicht weiterhelfen da gehört
dazu dass die atomkraftwerke ganz
bewusst offenbar eingesetzt werden um
diesen druck zu erzeugen oder sehen sie
da also ich muss ehrlich sagen
was das mit sushi und tschernobyl
eigentlich was da passiert ich habe
darüber zu wenig informationen und das
ist ohnehin ein ein konflikt wir sitzen
zu hause in unserem büro sicherlich
kennen wir alle leute aber ich gehöre
jetzt nicht zu denjenigen die vom
präsident des bnd jeden tag gebrieft
werden ich wäre bereit also wenn das
handy gehört sondern kennen ihn auch als
er werde ich würde ihnen willkommen
heißen über einem heißgetränk aber diese
information habe ich nicht und die frage
ist für mich wie weit ist das wirklich
intentional von putin zum beispiel jetzt
branche zu beschießen oder wie weit ist
da einfach ein durchgeknallter panzer
kommandeur vor ort der irgendwie
versucht es das geländer einzunehmen das
durchblick ich nicht und weit also ich
würde mich sehr schwer tun generell
diesem krieg von dingen die wir sehen in
den fernsehbildern bereits auf eine
intension russischer seite schließen
krieg ist chaos im krieg kann
unglaublich viel schief gehen ist kein
mix kommunikation geben es kann die eine
seite nicht wissen was die andere macht
also da würde ich mir zumindest jetzt
keine wirkliche strategie russlands zu
trauen das zweite was ganz offenbar von
wladimir putin unterschätzt worden ist
ist wie schnell der westen in
anführungsstrichen die nato staaten auch
die europäische union zusammen gestanden
haben und er sich einer front gegenüber
sah die er ganz gerne aufgeteilt gesehen
hätte der westen hat sehr schnell
reagiert erinnert mich so ein bisschen
anders also man sollte mit historischen
vergleichen vorsichtig sein sage ich
auch immer fragt als historiker sagte
aber es erinnert mich wirklich an den
august und september 1939 als hitler ja
glaubte der westen ist schwach der
westen mit protestieren aber er wird
unserem angriff unsere überfall auf
polen nichts entgegensetzen und ich
glaube dass putins wahrnehmung des
westens so war der westen schwach
sondern aus deutschland schwach sie
werden sich beklagen sie werden keine
ahnung versuchen meine yacht zu
konfiszieren aber ansonsten wird nicht
viel passieren und das kann man ja
erklären die dort gerade die deutschen
reaktionen von 2014 an aktion der
gemeinde jetzt nicht besonders kraftvoll
und wenn man auf die deutsche
sicherheitspolitik schaut
ist es vielleicht nicht eine besonders
kraftvolle sicherheitspolitik aber er
hat verkannt was friedrich merz das
schön genannt hat genug ist genug dass
irgendwann auch für die demokratin ein
punkt kommt wo die demokratien dann das
ruder rum werden und das erinnert mich
in der tat sehr an den ersten september
1939 wurde demokratien dann auch gesagt
haben genug ist genug und wir gehen
jetzt in die konfrontation
wir haben immer wieder festgestellt bei
tschetschenien bei syrien bei anderen
kriegen bei auseinandersetzungen in die
sich russland eingemischt haben der
westen hat sich aufgeteilt die einen
sagten ja wir müssen eigentlich was tun
die anderen haben gesagt ja aber das
wäre jetzt die kurve legt lasst ihn mal
die arbeit machen im zweifelsfall ist
danach ruhe war das nicht ein
riesenfehler ja ich glaube dass das die
wie vor den trümmern der europäischen
sicherheitspolitik insbesondere aber vor
den trümmern der deutschen
sicherheitspolitik stehen denn wir
deutschen haben ja eigentlich
natürlich gehofft dass nach der
wiedervereinigung aber auch nach dem
krieg also krieg gibt es irgendwie gar
nicht also krieg ist gar nicht mehr
führbar wir sprechen von einem
friedlichen den friedlichen 90er jahren
vergessen völlig dass da ein krieg auf
dem balkan tobte mit hunderttausend
toten und das ist eben die europäer
nicht geschafft haben das reparieren sda
zu verhindern dass waren die amerikaner
wieder und auch jetzt müssen wir uns ja
fragen sind die europäer in der lage ein
zweites srebrenica wenn es jetzt
pausieren zu einem krieg kommen würde zu
verhindern ein sind sie nicht und die
idee ist es im frieden ausgebrochen und
ja es gibt konflikte aber ich mache mit
reisediplomatie und handel lösen wir das
ist eben eine ganz große illusion und
ich glaube dass das ist gerade auch für
die sicherheitspolitik von angela merkel
steht man kann das erklären wir sollten
jetzt auch kein blame game betreiben
dann kann das aus der situation erklären
aber ich glaube dass gerade nach 2014
ist die an zeit gewesen wäre aufzuwachen
und den kopf aus dem sand zu stecken und
die welt zeigen sich durch eine rosarote
brille worden wenn wir bei der deutschen
verantwortung sind oder
dem gefühl die deutschen sollten daraus
geschäftskunden besser nicht mitmachen
haben wir immer wieder den konflikt
gehabt deutschland war aufgefordert als
nato land hat sich aber in eine andere
position zurückgezogen angestellt wir
haben damals bei libyen den klassischen
fall wo ein außenminister westerwelle
gesagt hat ich halte mich da raus wir
wollen diese flugverbotszone über libyen
nicht mitgestalten in anführungsstrichen
lasst uns dass die franzosen machen die
ich dann gemacht haben und in syrien
ähnlich in syrien ähnlich hat aber auf
der anderen seite dann die airbags über
afghanistan mit deutschen besetzt also
eigentlich hat man sich doch eigentlich
sehr sehr lange in die tasche gelogen
ich glaube dass schon wie man letztlich
würde ich aus heutiger sicht sagen was
gut sich in libyen nicht zu beteiligen
der libyenkrieg war war eine torheit
aber es geht um das prinzip also
westerwelle hat ja sogar verhindert dass
die deutschen mehr als ein evakuierungs
flug machen es gab ja eine
evakuierungsaktion der bundeswehr die
von greta gestartet sind und deutsche
ausgeflogen haben und nach einem flug
war schluss obwohl es doch deutsche im
land gab also es war schon ein aus
meiner sicht waren die deutschen wenn es
ums moralisieren ging wenn es darum ging
sorge auszudrücken auch in syrien etwa
ein rücktritt ersatz zu folgen also im
reden waren sie weltmeister wenn es um
taten ging auch die bekämpfung des zum
beispiel die roten linien giftgas von
ersatz waren die deutschen zwerge und
sie haben damit die europäische position
geschwächt und diese kommunikation an
putin glaube ich ganz genau verfolgt und
dass das europa gespalten ist dass
deutschland als ein wichtiges land auf
der bremse steht für nicht damit sagen
dass alles falsch war aber es war glaube
ich unrealistisch weil die deutschen
auch im auswärtigen amt militärische
mittel immer ausgeschlossen haben und es
gibt einige wenige diplomaten die gesagt
haben auch intern leute wir können das
nicht immer ausschließen keiner von uns
will militärische mittel einsetzt aber
wir können nicht von vornherein das
ausschließen und jan die deutschen haben
sich einfach immer hinter ihrer
geschichte versteckt und das war einfach
zu bequem und da sehen wir jetzt ja auch
ukraine konflikt erst sagen sie aus
historischen gründen dürfen wir da nicht
waffen liefern das ist natürlich unsinn
wie es dann die reaktion zu beurteilen
die wir jetzt haben vom bundeskanzler
wir haben ein angebot polens mit mit 29
die an die ukraine zu liefern
dann könnte auch eine luftüberlegenheit
russlands die im augenblick existiert
und schreckliche folgen hat
bombardierung
angebliche bombardierungen wir wissen
das ja alles nicht wirklich ganz genau
dieses kinderkrankenhauses sind mario
pohl mit schrecklichen bildern
verhindert werden oder zumindest
eingegrenzt werden aber da sagen die
amerikaner das ist uns zu kritisch das
ist uns zu gefährlich
und der bundeskanzler sagten die da
machen wir nicht mit ist das ein rückzug
in dieser form wie sie ihn jetzt den
vergangenen jahren ich bin auch ich
glaube nicht sondern ich glaube dass
diese mit 29 kiste einfach falsch
gespielt worden ist das ist so eine
heiße kartoffel die die polen den
amerikanern zugespielt haben die frage
ist schon wenn wir diese flugzeuge
liefern wir liefern andere waffen auch
über jetzt liefern wir diese waffen
überschreiten wir nicht eine bestimmte
grenze weil weil mit 29 anders
wahrgenommen werden als panzerfäuste ich
glaube es gibt ja diese illusion dass
nur defensivwaffen das ist natürlich
alles quatsch nicht also etwa ein panzer
falls auch offensiv einsetzen und es
geht um mit 29 irgendwer sagt er das mal
als kommentar das sind ja offensivwaffen
es auch unsinn er mit 29 jagdflugzeuge
die werden würden verwendet werden zum
schutz der ukrainischen zwee bevölkerung
und zum schutz der ukrainischen soldaten
aber das ist ein anderes waffensysteme
und ich glaube wenn die amerikaner nein
sagen weil sie denken das ist uns zu
heikel also dann ist es richtig von
bundeskanzler zu sagen also leute es ist
vielleicht nicht so sinnvoll wir machen
das lieber anders und man sollte auch
glaube ich waffenlieferungen jetzt nicht
in aller öffentlichkeit
ausbreiten es werden ja viele dinge
geliefert er verstehe ich auch andere
die wir nicht ja natürlich und das ist
jetzt keine sache dass wir erst mal die
listen im spiel veröffentlichen und erst
mal diskutieren also in dem moment wo
man das öffentlich gemacht hat wo man
das so gespielt hat was eigentlich tun
professionals haben
wir jetzt eine zeitenwende mit diesen
100 milliarden die deutschland auf den
tisch legt um die bundeswehr
in eine neue sagen wir mal kämpfer
position zu bringen denn letztendlich
heißt das ja eine menge geld dafür
auszugeben die bundeswehr auf ein niveau
zu heben um in der nato auch mitmachen
zu können ja bisher konnten wir
bestimmte dinge ja gar nicht mitmachen
weil wir die waffensysteme gar nicht hat
und ich würde weiter gehen also muss es
aussprechen es geht um die
kriegsbereitschaft der bundeswehr wir
lieben dieses wort nicht es war im
politischen berlin nicht vermittelbar
darum geht es wir sehen es jetzt krieg
in der ukraine es ist eine situation
dass man angst hat dass putin weiter
geht das baltikum oder polen angreift
und das ist krieg das ist nicht ein satz
ein satz klingt so nach mali oder so
oder nach uni viel an der küste libanons
es geht darum die bundeswehr krieg
bereit so machen wenn ein solcher krieg
ausbrechen dann ein beitrag zur
verteidigung zu leisten darum geht es
und ich glaube in der tat dass die
regierungserklärung von olaf scholz
ein mit der bemerkten
sicherheitspolitischen reden der letzten
50 jahre gewesen ist vielleicht in der
geschichte der bundesrepublik eine derbe
märkten bemerkenswerten
sicherheitspolitischen reden die frage
ist
bleibt es beim reden oder was folgt
darauf also ich würde hinter der
zeitenwende die sie eben als begriff
angesprochen ob ein fragezeichen setzen
mit bleistift ich abwarten was da muss
man abwarten genau und es sieht so aus
als ob olaf scholz wirklich sich jetzt
an die spitze als als richtlinien gebe
der politik an die spitze dieser
bewegung gesetzt hat ja wir müssen die
bundeswehr sei aber etwas
smith einsatzbereit machen und man hat
vorher dass immer einer
verteidigungsministerin staat seinen
generälen überlassen jetzt ist zum
ersten mal seit 30 jahren ist ein
bundeskanzler sagt so geht es nicht
weiter und wenn ich das richtig weiß hat
sich auch olaf scholz mit der
verteidigungsministerium den
staatssekretär und den generalinspekteur
zusammengesetzt und hat wirklich gesagt
wie bringen wir die sache voran und es
dieses fragezeichen ob wir wirklich
jetzt ergebnisse sehen ob die bundeswehr
wirklich einsatzbereit ihre bundes ihre
nato verpflichtung wirklich erfüllen
kann hängt von olaf scholz ab das ist
keine aufgabe die die
verteidigungsministerin alleine stemmen
kann es ist eine aufgabe des kabinetts
und olaf scholz muss sich letztlich
einen plan machen wann ist die erste
regatta einsatzbereit wenn die zweite
waren die dritte und wann also er muss
sagen wirklich die haken machen und man
muss für die bundeswehr zum ersten mal
seit 30 jahren ich sag jetzt mal ein
bisschen plakativ über den krieg denken
über einsatzbereitschaft und nicht über
den frieden und nicht über in britische
interessen wahlkreis interessen rüstungs
interessen so sagen es geht um die
einsatzbereitschaft was kriegen wir auf
den boden und wenn olaf scholz
da den finger drauf hat wenn er sagt ich
als kanzler will das weil die
nachforderungen werden kommen die nato
wird fordern nicht nur alle vier jahre
eine brigade sondern drei brigaden
ständig dina und die muss olaf scholz
unterschreiben nicht frau landrecht oder
der generalinspekteur
dafür muss er gerade stehen ich glaube
er ist jetzt einfach in der bütt in
dieser legislaturperiode wirklich einen
wesentlichen schritt voranzukommen und
dann glaube ich kann es auch gelingt sie
haben ein buch geschrieben deutsche
krieger das nicht ganz
immer positiv bewertet worden einmal
gesagt hat um gottes willen das ist ja
jemand der den krieg ganz großartig
findet da geht es darum dass sie gesagt
haben wir brauchen soldaten als krieger
das ist der schritt von dem wir alle
nichts wissen wollen ja ja ja ich hab
mein hund kommt wie jetzt in diese
fahren argument in diesem buch ist zu
sagen entweder schaffen wir die
bundeswehr ab was wir machen können als
endlich ein liberaler staat wir können
diskutieren
und wenn wir sie nicht abschaffen sollte
sich funktionsfähig sein und wie die
universitäten funktionsfähig sein sollen
ein sender wie phoenix funktionsfähig
sein sollte die polizei was auch und
eine bundeswehr die wir jetzt des
funktionalen
bringt uns nichts und es sehen wir jetzt
ja wenn wir in einer krise in einem
krieg wie der ukraine krieg der
inspekteur des heeres sagen muss wir
sind blank dann sage ich mich ja sage
ich mir dann hat offenbar die ganzen 30
milliarden 50 milliarden der letzten
jahre nicht viel gebracht deswegen ist
nicht im sinne von einsatzbereitschaft
so und ich sage das muss der zielpunkt
sein und so ist meine argumentation in
diesem punkt aber sie sagt ehrlich seid
ehrlich aber sind sie der meinung dass
wir
die bevölkerung die politik
in einen zustand versetzen können indem
wir bereit sind wieder einen krieg zu
führen die frage ist ja was tun wir wenn
nächstes jahr putin ich nehme jetzt den
worst case an polen oder litauen angriff
sagen wir dann dann sagen wir den
deutschen soldaten viel glück legt euch
auf den boden und wartet auf hilfe aber
krieg wären wir nicht führen ist dass
unsere antwort und die ukraine zeigen es
uns doch das wollen die demokratie
verteidigen muss dass man die freiheit
verteidigen muss im äußersten notfall
ich will das nicht sie wollen das auch
nicht wir alle wollen das nicht aber wie
reagieren wir auf eine auf einen
diktator für den krieg mittel der
politik ist da sage ich wir haben ja
streitkräfte wir haben uns bewusst
entschieden streitkräfte zu haben auch
große streitkräfte einsatzbereite
streitkräfte nicht wir sind
vielleicht moore capital in österreich
oder so nicht und wir wollen manchmal
wie eine große schweiz seien aber selbst
die schweiz hat eine armee
und würde wahrscheinlich sagen ja wir
müssen unsere freiheit verteidigen und
unsere freiheit wird nicht an der oder
verteidigt sondern an der wachsen
und das wollen auch die polen von uns
hören wenn ich in stettin im
nato-hauptquartier bin fragen mich
polnische offiziere herrn einzel was tun
die deutschen und der kanzler hat ja
gesagt in seiner regierungserklärung wir
werden jeden quadratmeter nato boden
verteidigen so jetzt frage ich sie was
heißt denn dass das ist letztlich wir
wer sind bereit zur verteidigung
litauens des baltikums polens
ein krieg zu führen einen
verteidigungskrieg es geht nicht um
angriffskriege des 19 wir sind bereit
unsere freiheit zu verteidigen so und
das ist mein argument wenn das so ist
dann muss die bundeswehr in den zustand
versetzt werden das auch zu tun und dazu
gehört materialstruktur aber dazu gehört
auch eine mentalität weil sie und ich
werde wahrscheinlich dazu nicht in der
lage aber wenn wir da soldaten frauen
und männer hinschicken die unsere
freiheit verteidigen sollen dann müssen
sie auch dazu mental in der lage sein
muss man muss einem klar sein was heißt
das und das ist was anderes als auf
ganze solisten lagen ja gerne dazu mit
großen begriffen zu argumentieren oder
zu spekulieren wenn wir von einer
zeitenwende gesprochen haben einer
zeitenwende die sich dokumentiert hat
wir haben darüber gesprochen 100
milliarden für die bundeswehr sind wir
an einer zeitenwende auch historisch
angekommen und sie sind historiker bei
dem wir krieg wieder als ein mittel der
politik sehen beziehungsweise in einem
zeitpunkt wieder angekommen sind wo ein
krieg auch ein großer krieg wieder
möglich ist also krieg war immer ein
mittel der politik wir müssen sehen dass
die nato und auch deutschland hier an
kriegen beteiligt war also in
afghanistan würde ich schon sagen hat
einen krieg getobt und
die nato hat dort krieg geführt gegen
die taliban und gegen andere
aufständische es gab krieg in
jugoslawien da auch da hat sich die nato
auch mit deutscher beteiligung um
eingemischt wir dürfen auch nicht naiv
sein wir reden uns dass so ein bisschen
selber schön als ob die welt in der
letzten 30 jahre ohne kriege ausgekommen
ist eine ist ja nicht so die deutschen
waren auch beteiligt in diesen
konflikten das ist natürlich etwas
anderes als das was jetzt stattfindet
und ich bin der meinung es gibt zwei
möglichkeiten entweder sagen wir
wir kapitulieren vor putin und
akzeptieren so eine weltordnung das kann
glaube ich kein vernünftiger mensch mit
dem was wir sehen in der ukraine fordern
und dann sage ich ja also von uns will
keine kriege führen also es ist ein
absolutes drama was dort passiert also
schockierend schlimm fürchterlich nicht
also die welt muss doch anders zusammen
leben können ich bin absolut dieser
meinung ich bin wissenschaftler also
bitte die wissenschaft fördern den
freien austausch wichtig habe studenten
aus der ukraine aus russland überall auf
der welt aber wir müssen eine antwort
finden so und da würde ich sagen es gibt
nicht nur jetzt darum aufzurüsten krieg
und bundeswehr natürlich wird die
diplomatie ne rolle weiterspielen
natürlich wird wirtschaft eine rolle
natürlich wird kultureller austausch
weiterhin eine rolle spielen aber wir
müssen dürfen nicht naiv sein und ich
glaube zum beispiel briten und franzosen
haben diese naivität nie gehabt auch in
zehn ländern nicht die dänen nicht wir
haben uns ein bisschen eine rosarote
welt bewegt und wir müssen bereit sein
unsere freiheit zu verteidigen im
äußersten notfall ich hoffe dass es dazu
nicht kommt ich hätte gesagt glaube auch
nicht dass es dazu kommt aber be
prepared sonst lösen wir die bundeswehr
auch wenn wir sie nicht auflösen sollte
sie zumindest funktional sein und wir
sollten nicht auch sprachlich ein neuer
tanz vollführen sondern sagen wir sehen
ja die bilder aus der ukraine um was
geht ist und darauf sollten wir
vorbereitet sein und da war man im
kalten krieg weiter ohne dass man im
kalten krieg es ging ja nicht darum
jetzt uns als verteidigungsgemeinschaft
zu sehen und wieder bunker zu bauen also
müssen wir auch realistisch sein wer als
unser gegner das ist nicht die
sowjetunion es ist russland mit viel
geringeren ressourcen des jahres 2022
also mein plädoyer auch um meinen fokus
einfach seit realistisch und seid
ehrlich
danke dass ihr beide waren sehr gerne
dankeschön
[Musik]